so phenomenal to be able to say that
this film is here and that we've seen it
and that it is really that immersive
world that I think people are really
expecting
is it now that you're just going to work
with James on movies that have to do
with water forever like anytime you call
it that would be nice oh my God that
would be nice I mean I just the thing
with Jim is that you always feel so safe
because everything is precision it's
planned he's thought about it for
decades literally
um and of course he only has the best
professionals to facilitate his
wonderful Vision so the freediving
expert we worked with Kirk crock was so
thorough that I always felt looked after
and it gave us the not just the ability
to hold our breath for really long
periods of time but it gave us the
freedom as actors to really be able to
perform underwater for at length
um and at depth which is quite hard to
do but it was amazing I loved it I
imagine that anytime you take on a role
there's you're invited by some of the
challenge of it like you want some of
the challenge of it but when he's
telling you what you're going to be
doing does it progressively like in your
mind or going okay wait what oh and then
we're going to do what and now I have to
I'm going to be underwater for how long
like or do you just go yes I trust you
implicitly oh you just go yes I trust
you implicitly and also I know that he's
gonna say okay do this and try this and
then we're gonna do this okay um yeah
okay good and then I know he's gonna add
like five other things to that and he
will know that I will be completely open
to doing those extra things on top of
the three that he just told me to do
um I love it I mean and actually there's
something really empowering about
working with a director who expects a
lot of you in a physical sense and an
emotional sense and also for me having
evolved and changed hopefully and
learned a lot over the over the years I
knew that walking into this gym was
going to expect a lot of me because I
was there for a finite period of time I
knew what the role was I knew the
bonding that I had to do really quickly
with the young actors and that was
really special for me because I love
working with younger performers and so
building that trust and being given
permission by Jim to truly just help
them and nurture them and support them I
loved all of it it was wonderful yeah
sitting in that theater watching this in
3D this is like the example of the magic
that people talk about about being in
the theater and seeing something on
screen and being immersed in it as a
viewer we get that but as the person who
was playing that role and you know again
being underwater going through all of
that when you sit down and you watch it
do you feel that magic as well do you
get transported or are you thinking
about what you did to get there I
haven't seen the film
got it so I just finished something nine
days ago and I'm gonna get to see the
movie with everyone else
on Tuesday at the premiere and that's
actually the first time this will have
ever happened to me that I will really
get that audience experience and I
cannot wait my twin brother-in-laws are
coming with their Partners my husband's
going to be there like I just can't wait
for it I'm really gonna get to do it
just like everyone else that's awesome
yeah I could well thank you so much for
your time thank you